Nintendo rocked the world yesterday when
they released the trailer for their new
console dubbed the switch but even
though a lot was shown in the video some
details about the system are still
shrouded in mystery so here are the
seven biggest unanswered questions that
we have about the switch
Nintendo is a reputation of releasing
their consoles at a very competitive
price the Super Nintendo the n64 and
GameCube all launched with $199 price
tags while the Wii and Wii U were
released at 249 and $2.99 respectively
if Nintendo plans to keep with their
tradition of pricing their system's
lower than the competition there's a
chance that we'll see it cost less than
$300 considering that's how much the
Xbox one and ps4 currently cost the
Nintendo switch is being touted as both
a home console and a portable system
which brings up the big question about
battery life according to Nvidia who
crafted a custom Tegra processor made
specifically for the switch the system
will be optimized for efficiency with
the graphics card making it a powerful
yet very efficient console but as with
any handheld the number one thing on
everyone's mind is how long we can go
until we have to plug the system in
the trailer for the switch revealed a
lot about the hardware but also revealed
a lot about the kinds of games that
we'll see on the console as well so far
we can expect Skyrim NBA 2k Mario Mario
Kart and even a new splatoon game but
what else can we expect Nintendo is
notorious for neglecting some franchises
that fans love but also introducing some
great new ones as well but I think a lot
of us can agree that we just want a new
f-zero that's all
while most consoles today are some form
of black white gray or somewhere in
between
some of us long for the days of the
multicolored systems and we might
actually get that with the switch upon
closer inspection of the trailer the
face of the controller seems to be
translucent and not connected to the
handles opening the door for swappable
face plates similar to what Nintendo did
with the 3d s and having this option
could definitely add a little bit flare
to this generation of consoles one of
the main features of the Wii U and it
was announced was the inclusion of a
touchscreen on the controller and while
the switch does have a screen as part of
the controller it's unclear whether or
not it's an actual touchscreen at no
point the trailer does anyone actually
put their finger on it implying that it
might just be another regular monitor
and that might put into question any
theories of backwards compatibility
speaking of which
as much as we all love playing are we
you games on the Wii U there's a big
mystery surrounding
backwards-compatibility on the switch
looking at the trailer the switch
doesn't appear to have any disk drives
as all of the games will be on
cartridges but the last couple of
Nintendo consoles have had at least some
backwards compatibility so the question
remains will the switch be able to play
Wii U games will we be able to transfer
our Wii U purchases over to the switch
will there be a touchscreen and on for
Wii U games
come on Nintendo we gotta know
maybe the most concerning question of
all is if Nintendo sees the switch as
both a home console and a portable one
where will that leave the 3ds while
we're pretty certain that the switch
doesn't have dual screens or 3d
capabilities we do know that it's made
to be taken on the go so that poses the
question is the switch going to be the
all-in-one solution for both home and
portable consoles if Nintendo plans to
merge their eco system into one machine
they're going to have to tell that to
their 60 million 3ds users and I don't
think it'll be pretty those are the
questions about the switch that we want
answered but I'm sure there are
countless others that you're just dying
to ask let me know in the comments below
and for more coverage about the switch
and all your other favorite consoles
stay tuned the game spots